- Hi everyone, Sal here from Khan Academy.
As I'm sure you're aware,
we are finding ourselves
collectively, our planet,
in a very interesting situation right now
and a lot of unfortunate
things are happening.
And one of those unfortunate things is
the potential for school closures.
And so, all of us here at Khan Academy,
we've essentially stopped what we're doing
and we view it as our duty
to be able to support you through this,
to help you help ensure that
students continue to learn.
I know a lot of districts are facing
a lot of difficult decisions to make,
thinking about whether to close,
whether to virtualize,
there's a lot of equity issues at stake,
who has access to internet
and computers at home?
There's other things around childcare,
free and reduced lunch.
But we're gonna try and do our part
to support everyone as much as possible.
Big picture, if you have younger kids,
if you're a parent and you
have younger kids at home,
early elementary or even Pre-K,
I think the key is to focus on the basics,
even if students are
able to put in a solid
two hours of learning per day,
that will at least keep them on track.
I would focus on reading.
So that could be, if they aren't able
to read on their own
yet, reading with them.
We're going to be sending
out reading lists,
different activities you
could with your students,
and some form of mathematics.
We have Khan Academy Kids free app,
non-commercial, anyone can download it.
And that has over a
hundred books available
that you could read with your child.
It will also read to your child.
We think the best use case
of Khan Academy Kids is maybe
in sessions of about 20 minutes.
Ideally, with your child next to an adult,
you or an older sibling.
And that covers not just Pre-K
through 1st grade standards math,
but it also covers reading, writing
and social emotional learning.
On top of that, if your student has time
to do some handwriting practice,
we think that is great.
Or some type of journaling
if they are already at that level.
As we get into later
elementary, middle school,
Khan Academy Math, we think can
be really valuable for them,
help them stay on track.
You can start them at their grade level.
We're often times seeing a lot of success
if kids start well before grade level,
and then are able to master their way
all the way through grade level.
I would recommend also
for the older elementary
and the middle school students to have
at least an hour day of
reading that could be broken up
into two 30 minute sessions if needed.
Once again, we're gonna try to provide
some reading lists and things like that.
As you get into middle
school, early high school
and high school, we have even
more resources for students
on top of what I just talked about,
about the mathematics, which we have,
it goes from Pre-K all the
way through early college.
We can help those
students with enrichment.
Things like computer programming.
We'll also provide reading lists for them.
Also, in the sciences, I
think students as early
as middle school and
definitely in high school.
Obviously, biology is of interest today.
Glass half-full, that could
be a learning opportunity.
Learn about viruses,
learning how disease spread.
Learn about exponential growth.
I think a lot of students
at the middle school
and high school level
could begin to engage
in our high school level biology,
or even some of our high
school level chemistry.
As you get into the core of high school,
above and beyond those things,
we have high school level physics.
We have economics, macro/micro economics,
American history, civics and government
at both the high school
and the advanced placement,
early college level.
And on top that we have
official SAT practice.
So if you're an older
student, I would recommend
you could structure your day even longer.
We're gonna be giving out some schedules
that you could work from, so
that you can stay on track,
to be prepared, to get college ready,
and make sure that you don't
have any lost learning.
So we'll be setting out more details,
more videos, more
information, as we learn more.
But we are doing everything
we can to make sure
that we can have you covered.
It's our duty as a
not-for-profit with a mission
of free, world class
education for anyone anywhere
to support you in this
very challenging time.